what are your like top five albums
albums ever not the best album but your
personal favorite
uh first I'm gonna say ready to die I
mean no pause life after death if I say
life after death but I mean some people
like ready to die because they're
nostalgic purposes nah you gotta realize
what my age ready to die was a little
before my time life after death I
connected with you know I'm saying so I
would say life after death Mobb Deep
Murder music okay Jay-Z Blueprint all
right
Nas it was written
great great nice album oh affirmative
actions top five not a song ever Dr Dre
The Chronic
the first one yeah I like that but West
Coast in there yeah because that was the
first that I remember the OG's like
playing that really had a heavy
influence on my on my you know and uh
yeah that was heavy